so here's brian stelter who reliable
sources he's supposed to be the media
watchdog
and instead of of course he is just joe
biden's lap dog here he was uh honestly
i'm just go my new
nickname for the main for the
establishment media when it comes to
democratic administrations they're the
human centipede they're just the human
centipede anyway
here's here's brian stelter explaining
that joe biden is making
news boring again he's making news more
see here's the thing
if you were a news person brian stelter
the news would not be boring
he's pursuing some fairly radical policy
right off the bat we'll get to that in a
moment
but it's boring because you see all you
wanted to cover trump made their job so
easy
he really did the reason that trump made
their job easy is because every day they
would get up
they would look at trump's twitter feed
and that would decide what they covered
that day
he would literally just tweet out the
news cycle he'd be like
this country is a bleep i mean oh my god
that's 12 hours of content get me a
panel
jamelle hill i i won't get i you know i
need on air right now get michael eric
dyson on the phone stat the president
tweeted out that a country
is a bleep hole country and everybody's
like that okay yeah that's
like not right but i'm just wondering
what that has to do with policy
i'm like no no no no no no no not normal
we're gonna have 12 hours of not normal
with chirons
not normal right that was the whole the
entire trump administration was that
the truth is the saddest people in the
world in the media that trump's twitter
got banned
are the members of the media because now
they actually are supposed to have to do
their jobs but here's the thing they're
not going to do their jobs
instead they have literally their new
policy in the media
is to declare themselves irrelevant i've
never seen
anything like this in the media we felt
that we were relevant during the trump
administration because we were calling
balls and strikes i'm a conservative i
was going to give you my opinion of what
trump did i was going to give you my
opinion of yes the tweets but also the
policy
the media were like no we're not going
to cover the policy at all we're just
going to cover the tweets
and then everything with regard to
policy will be seen through the prism of
the tweets
but now that a democrat is in the white
house and the democrats have congress
now the media are declaring that they no
longer are relevant
i've never heard of anything like this
it's amazing
they have the same perspective about
their job that i would if i were a
politician which is my job would be to
make myself irrelevant so you can live
your life but the media their job is not
to be irrelevant their job
is to cover the news but here's brian
stelter of reliable sources explaining
basically we're done the news is boring
you don't have to watch anymore
turn off cnn what is going on here
here's brian stelter
is president biden making the news
boring again
people are always asking what the media
will do post president trump
this week after biden's inauguration
they've been asking are reporters going
through withdrawal
are they missing trump's tweets are they
lost without outrages to cover
these headlines from from axios and
other websites point out that the
biden's plan is dull
by design so is he making the news
boring again is he is he making the news
point so and then he shows a couple of
headlines right axios biden's dull by
design plan the atlantic boring is
better mashable joe biden's first
presidential tweet is refreshingly
boring see he's so normal guys
normal boring with normalcy and
boringness
isn't that amazing by the way stelter
then tweeted out a chiron
on his show this is the chiron saki
promises to share
accurate info in parentheses how
refreshing
what do you think your job is brian
stelter like seriously
what do you perceive your job to be how
refreshing
okay so here's the thing every single
person who gets up at the white house
podium says they're about to provide you
accurate information they then lie to
you
okay this has happened for every single
white house press secretary of whom i'm
aware
some of them lied less than others dana
perino and ari fleischer
lied less than robert gibbs and jay
carney but the the basic idea
that you in the media be like how
refreshing a politician has promised me
honesty
literally the opposite of your job your
job is to say yes i know you're
promising me honesty
and now i'm going to hold you
accountable but they don't do that they
have no intention
of doing that i mean the wild shift
between look how normal
and boring this is and five minutes ago
it was everything is a crisis every
single thing is a crisis
it's absolutely astonishing right here's
a flashback right here
so brian stelter was saying this is
we're back to normal guys it's boring
it's normal
this is brian stelter just a few months
ago being like nothing is normal
there's not a single thing that's
happening that's normal right now
it's like new orleans floods every day
it's like the plains go into the towers
every day
and to look away or act like it's now
normal
or acceptable is a disgrace to the
victims
okay i'm just going to point out while
you guys are talking about joe biden's
ice cream flavor
well you guys are talking about how
normal joe biden is and the new boring
and the new normal more people are dying
on a daily basis in the united states
than have ever died from covet in the
entire history of covet
just gonna point that out so if we were
if we were the media and we were to
cover this consistently right now
brian stelter would have been on tv
yesterday he'd been like look there was
joe biden tweeting out about chocolate
chip ice cream
yesterday was 9 11 in the united states
yesterday planes were flying into
buildings in the united states and this
guy was
tweeting about chocolate chip ice cream
how did
this is not normal but no no they're
never gonna do that right cause it's so
normal everything's normal
and the media are determined to talk
about how normal this is
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content